Le bêtisier.
- Ça tourne toujours.
- Tourne toujours, comme ta mère.
Excellent !
Ouais, c'est un cancer du doigt.
- Allez !
- Prends le maximum !
Depuis le temps !
- J'ai gagné un code de téléchargement.
- Et moi j'ai une Fiat Punto Panda,
500, break.
- Je me suis fait baisé.
C'est pas vrai.
- Tu me donnes un autographe ?
- Merci !
- Au revoir.
- Maintenant ce vase.
Par contre, y a une chose que je sais,
Ça fait un maximum d'argent !
Y en a pas un qui l'a dit,
la bonne phrase.
- Ben, il se démerde.
- Je comprends pas bien la [inaudible].
Mon articulation, je la comprends pas.
Ce que je dis, je ne le comprends pas.
Oh putain !
Samsung, ils veulent vendre…
- Samsung, ils veulent enlever
les chargeurs de leurs boites…
Samsung, ils veulent enlever les chargeurs…
Samsung, ils enlèvent les chargeurs…
C'est hyper dur, c'est dur.
- Samsung ils enlèvent les…
- J'enlève ?
- Non !
Non !
- Pour notre prochaine série,
j'ai mis un budget
de fous !
- En tout cas, pas dans tes cours de théâtre.
- Oh putain…
- Pour notre prochaine série,
j'ai mis un budget de….
Pourquoi t'as criée ?
Oui, vous êtes le premier homme
à être le plus riche.
Ça veut rien dire.
- Catastrophe !
S'il vous plaît Mr. Hans Zimmer
une dernière musique.
- « Danke schön. »
« Bitte sehr. »
« Auf Wiedersehen. »
- « Auf Wiedersehen.
« Bis Bald Dr Zimmer. »
- Action !
Elle est où Hélène ?
- Je sais pas.
- Demandez parce qu'il passe d'accord,
je peux pas changer.
- Pas mal le métaverse en fait,
j'aime bien.
- Mais oui, on est en réunion
tout en restant en slip chez nous, j'adore !
Elle est où Elaine ?
- Je sais pas.
- Demandez parce qu'il passe d'accord,
je peux pas changer.
- Mais attends…
[inaudible.]
- Oh pardon.
- Ah, pardon.
- Pourquoi tu tapes si fort ?
- Et merde, on ne fait que perdre…
- Attends…
- Attends, c'est moi.
OK, c'est bon.
- Et merde, on ne fait que perdre…
[inaudible.]
Putain, je l'ai pas en français.
Arrêtez de me…
- Je veux être le premier,
je veux de l'argent.
Le VTT il était petit comme ça.
- Ça, c'est bon.
Pourquoi ça ?
- On enlève le téléphone.
- Ah non.
- Il s'est cassé.
- Tout va bien,
tout va bien.
- J'ai mis un budget de fous
sur notre prochaine série.
Ça va cartonner !
- J'espère que c'est pas encore l'adaptation
d'un animé en live parce que…
J'espère que c'est pas encore un animé…
Ah putain !
J'espère que c'est pas une adaptation live…
J'espère que c'est pas…
J'espère que c'est pas encore un animé.
J'ai envie de crever, putain.
Je viens de croiser à l'instant
le ministre du chômage.
Le ministre de l'Économie ?
Je viens de croiser à l'instant même
le ministre du chômage,
dans les affaires étrangères.
- Et voilà,
je viens de lui passer dans,
dedans.
Je viens de lui passer dedans.
Je viens de lui passer dans,
dedans !
- Pour les fêtes, on va cartonner.
Ne vous inquiétez pas.
- Tu veux téter chéri ?
- Non.
- Les réunions coupées.
Chez Twitch  :
- C'est la catastrophe !
On s'est fait pirater.
- Quoi ?
- Les hackers ont dévoilés
les salaires de tout le monde.
- Les gens savent combien on gagne !
- Oh mon Dieu.
- Ah non, le salaire des streamers.
- Ça, c'est une fuite
qu'on réparera plus tard.
- Chez Facebook  :
- On appelle le métaverse,
allez au travail.
- Mais ta gueule.
Chip's.
- Chez Netflix  :
- J'ai mis un budget de fous
sur notre prochaine série.
Ça va cartonner !
- J'espère que c'est pas encore l'adaptation
live d'un animé Japonais parce que…
- C'est vrai qu'a chaque fois c'est un four  :
Cowboy Bebop, Death Note.
- Squid game saison 2.
- Squid game saison 2 !
- Bonne idée ça.
- C'est bien ça.
- Chez les NFT  :
- Ça cartonne dans NFT.
- Regarde tout le pognon qu'on se fait.
- Quel succès !
Par contre juste comme ça,
parce que moi je sais.
Mais votre définition de NFT ?
- Ah ben NFT, c'est très simple.
C'est quand tu…
Mais Hélène, elle le dit bien.
- Quand tu pars vers la…
Après tu…
Tu prends et…
J'ai aucune idée de ce que c'est.
- Oh putain,
moi non plus.
Je pige que dalle,
je sais pas ce que c'est.
- Par contre y a un truc que je sais,
on se fait un maximum de thune !
- Chez Waze  :
- À la semaine prochaine, messieurs.
[inaudible]
- Je le signale sur l'application.
Ah, nouvelle itinéraire.
- Voilà !
Ah, ben ça roule bien.
- Chez Marvel  :
- Pour le nouveau Spider-Man,
on va prendre  :
Docteur Octopus et Electro.
- C'est impossible !
- Ah oui,
ils viennent de différents reboot
de la franchise.
- Mais si, grâce au multiverse.
- Le multiverse.
Moi je le sais,
mais comment vous le définiriez
le multiverse ?
- Au Zevent  :
- Est-ce que vous avez un nom
précis d'association, s'il vous plaît ?
- La communauté de la Rocket League, je…
11 millions !
- 11 millions d'euros !
11 millions pour
les enfants.